if you work in the NHS the healthcare
crisis can feel like a financial crisis
too Sean drives an ambulance but his pay
rarely carries him to the end of the
month I'm working maybe 25 30 hours
overtime every month
to uh to top up my salary because the
cost of living
the economic crisis that we're all
experience and money goal isn't going as
far as what it did I would struggle to
make ends meet
personally I have to work the hours I
wish I could finish on my finish time
every single day and spend quality time
with my family I'm a three and a half
year old granddaughter
but I have to work overtime
Sean will be on strike again next week
and nurses for 48 hours from tomorrow as
public sector workers try and combat a
cost of living squeeze starkly apparent
in the latest figures
while overall pay is rising there's a
growing gap between private sector wages
up 7.2 percent in the three months to
November compared to 3.3 percent in the
public sector
neither is enough to keep up with
inflation meaning that in real terms
wages fell by 3.8 percent also falling
the number of vacancies down for an
eighth successive month still
historically high but a sign perhaps the
labor market is Cooling
demand for work has remains strong as
economic inactivity largely through
long-term sickness and the consequences
of brexit shrink the workforce that
unemployment has ticked up too so is the
economic slowdown finally catching up
with the jobs market we've probably got
sick months of this sort of
being in great demand but I do think
thereafter it probably will level off
people in the in the public sector now
are looking and looking at the
opportunities available realizing that
they could probably you know get better
better sort of opportunities pay etc etc
in the private sector with 1.6 million
working days already lost strikes more
will follow rail workers will stage two
walkouts next month even as they
negotiate new pay deals in a market that
may soon take a turn for the worse
[Applause]